جزاك الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
[Silence]
الله
استووا استووا اعتدلوا
سد
الفرج الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
سيقول
السفهاء من الناس ما ولاهم عن قبلتهم التي
كانوا عليها قل لله المشرق والمغرب يهدي
من يشاء الى صراط
مستقيم وكذلك جعلناكم امه وسطا لتكونوا
شهداء على الناس ويكون الرسول عليكم
شهيدا وما جعلنا القبله التي كنت عليها
الا لنعلم من يتبع الرسول ممن ينقلب على
عقبيه وان كانت لك
الا على الذين هدى
الله وما كان الله ليضيع
ايمانكم ان الله بالناس لرؤوف
رحيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين قد نرى تقلب وجهك في السماء
فلنولينك
قبله
ترضاها فول وجهك شطر المسجد
الحرام وحيث ما كنتم فولوا وجوهكم
شطره وان الذين اوتوا الكتاب ليعلمون انه
الحق من ربهم وما الله بغافل عما
يعملون ولئن اتيت الذين اوتوا الكتاب بكل
ايه ما تبعوا
قبلتك وما انت بتابع قبلتهم وما بعضهم
بتابع قبله
بعض ولئن اتبعت
اهواءهم من بعد ما جاءك من العلم انك اذا
لمن
الظالمين الذين اتيناهم الكتاب
يعرفونه كما يعرفون
ابناءهم وان فريقا منهم ليكتمون الحق وهم
يعلمون الحق من ربك فلا تكونن من الممترين
ولكل وجهه هو
موليها فاستبقوا
الخيرات اينما تكونوا يات بكم الله
جميعا ان الله على كل شيء
قدير الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر س سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏se
استووا صلاه
التراويح استو
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ومن حيث خرجت فول وجهك شطر المسجد
الحرام وانه للحق من ربك وما الله بغافل
عما
تعملون ومن حيث خرجت فول وجه ك شطر المسجد
الحرام وحيث ما كنتم فولوا وجوهكم
شطره لاللا يكون للناس عليكم حجه الا
الذين ظلموا منهم فلا تخشوهم واخشوني
ولاتم نعمتي
عليكم ولاتم نعمتي عليكم ولعلكم
تهتدون كما ارسلنا فيكم
رسولا منكم يتلو عليكم اياتنا
ويزكيكم ويزكيكم ويعلمكم الكتاب والحكمه
ويعلمكم ما لم تكونوا
تعلمون
فاذكروني اذكركم واشكروا لي ولا
تكفرون يا ايها الذين امنوا استعينوا
بالصبر
والصلاه ان الله مع
الصابرين ولا تقولوا لمن يقتل في سبيل
الله اموات بل
احياء ولكن لا
تشعرون
ولنبلونكم بشيء من الخوف والجوع ونقص من
الاموال والانفس والثمر
وبشر
الصابرين الذين اذا
اصابتهم مصيبه قالوا انا لله وانا اليه
راجعون اولئك عليهم صلوات من ربهم ورحمه
واولئك هم
المهتدون ان الصفى مروه من
شعائر
الله فمن حج البيت او اعتمر فلا جناح عليه
ان يطوف بهما ومن تطوع خيرا فان الله شاكر
عليم ان الذين يكتمون ما انزلنا من
البينات والهدى من بعد ما بيناه ل الناس
في الكتاب اولئك يلعنهم الله ويلعنهم
اللاعنون الا الذين تابوا واصلحوا
وبينوا فاولئك اتوب عليهم وانا التواب
الرحيم ان الذين كفروا وماتوا وهم كفار
اولئك عليهم لعنه الله وال
الملائكه والناس
اجمعين خالدين فيها لا يخفف عنهم العذاب
ولا هم
ينظرون
والهكم اله
واحد لا اله الا هو الرحمن
الرحيم الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Silence]
امين ان في خلق السماوات والارض واختلاف
الليل والنهار والفلك التي تجري في البحر
بما ينفع
الناس وما انزل الله من الس السماء من ماء
فاحيا به الارض بعد موتها وبث
فيها وبث فيها من كل
دابه وتصريف الرياح والسحاب المسخر بين
السماء والارض
لايات لايات لقوم يعقلون
ومن الناس من يتخذ من دون الله اندادا
يحبونهم كحب
الله والذين امنوا اشد حبا
لله ولو يرى الذين ظلموا اذ يرون العذاب
ان القوه لله جميعا وان الله شديد
العذاب اذ تبرا الذين اتبعوا من الذين
اتبعوا وراوا العذاب وتقطعت بهم
الاسباب وقال الذين اتبعوا لو ان لنا كره
فنتبعه الله اعمالهم حسرات عليهم وما هم
بخارجين من
النار يا ايها ال الناس كلوا من يا ايها
الناس كلوا مما في الارض حلالا طيبا ولا
تتبعوا خطوات
الشيطان انه لكم عدو
مبين انما يامركم بالسوء والفحشاء وان
تقولوا على الله ما لا
تعلمون واذا قيل لهم تبعوا ما انزل الله
قالوا بل نتبع ما الفينا عليه
اباءنا اولو كان
اباؤهم لا يعقلون شيئا ولا
يهتدون ومثل الذين كفروا كمثل الذي ينعق
بما لا يسمع الا
دعاء
ونداء صم بكم عمي
فهم لا
يعقلون يا ايها الذين امنوا قلوا من طيبات
ما رزقناكم واشكروا لله ان كنتم اياه
تعبدون انما حرم عليكم الميته والدم ولحم
الخنزير وما اهل به لغير
الله فمن اطر غير باغ ولا عاد فلا اثم
عليه ان الله غفور
رحيم ان الذين يكتمون ما انزل الله من
الكتاب ويشترون به ثمنا قليلا
اولئك ما ياكلون في بطونهم الا
النار ولا يكلمهم الله يوم القيامه
ولا يزكيهم ولهم عذاب
اليم اولئك الذين اشتروا الضلاله بالهدى
والعذاب
بالمغفره فما اصبرهم على
النار ذلك بان الله نزل الكتاب
بالحق وان الذين اختلفوا في الكتاب لفي
شقاق
عي الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام علكم
عليكم رحم
[Silence]
الله الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ليس البر ان تولوا وجوهكم قبل المشرق
والمغرب ولكن ان البر من امن بالله واليوم
الاخر
والملائكه والكتاب
والنبيين واتى المال على حبه ذوي القربى
واليتامى والمساكين وابن السبيل
والسائلين وفي
الرقاب واقام الصلاه واتى الزكاه والموفون
بعهدهم اذا عاهدوا
والصابرين في
الباساء
والضراء وحين
الباس
اولئك الذين صدقوا واولئك هم
المتقون يا ايها الذين امنوا كتب عليكم
القصاص في
القتلى الحر بالحر والعبد بالعبد والانثى
بالانثى
فمن عفي له من اخيه شيء فاتباع
بالمعروف
واداء اليه
باحسان ذلك تخفيف من ربكم ورحمه فمن اعتدى
بعد ذلك فله عذاب
اليم ولكم في القصاص حياه يا اولي الالباب
لعلكم
تتقون كت كتب عليكم اذا حضر احدكم الموت
ان ترك خيرا الوصيه للوالدين والاقربين
بالمعروف حقا على
المتقين فمن بدله بعد ما سمعه فانما اثمه
على الذين
يبدلونه ان الله سميع
عليم فمن خاف فمن موص جنفا او اثما فاصلح
بينهم فلا اثم
عليه ان الله غفور
رحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا كتب عليكم
الصيام كما كتب على الذين من قبلكم لعلكم
تتقون اياما
معدودات فمن كان منكم مريض او على سفر
فعده من ايام اخر وعلى الذين يطيقونه فديه
طعام مسكين فمن تطوع خيرا فهو خير له وان
تصوموا خير لكم ان كنتم
تعلمون شهر رمضان الذي انزل فيه القران
هدى للناس وبينات
من الهدى
والفرقان فمن شهد منكم الشهر فليصمه ومن
كان مريضا او على سفر فعده من ايام اخر
يريد الله بكم اليسر ولا يريد بكم العسر
ولتكملوا العده ولتكبروا الله على ما
هداكم ولعلكم تشكرون
واذا سالك عبادي عني فاني
قريب فاني قريب اجيب دعوه الداع اذا
دعان فليستجيبوا لي وليؤمنوا
فليستجيبوا لي وليؤمنوا بي لعلهم يرشدون
احل لكم ليله الصيام الرفث الى
نسائكم هن لباس لكم وانتم لباس
لهن علم الله انكم كنتم تختانون انفسكم
فتاب عليكم وعفى
عنكم فالان باشروهن
وابتغوا ما كتب الله لكم وكلوا واشربوا
حتى يتبين لكم الخيط الابيض من الخيط
الاسود من
الفجر ثم اتموا الصيام الى
الليل ولا تباشروهن
وانتم عاكفون في المساجد تلك حدود الله
فلا
تقربوها كذلك يبين الله اياته للناس لعلهم
يتقون
ولا تاكلوا اموالكم بينكم بالباطل وتدلوا
بها الى الحكام لتاكلوا
فريقا لتاكلوا فريقا من اموال الناس
بالاثم وانتم
تعلمون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يسالونك عن
الاهله قل مواقيت للناس
والحج وليس البر بان تاتوا البيوت من
ظهورها ولكن البر من اتقى واتوا البيوت من
ابوابها واتقوا
الله واتقوا الله لعلكم
تفلحون وقاتلوا في سبيل الله الذين
يقاتلونكم ولا تعتدوا
ان الله لا يحب
المعتدين واقتلوهم حيث ثقفتموهم
واخرجوهم من حيث
اخرجوكم والفتنه اشد من القتل ولا
تقاتلوهم عند المسجد الحرام حتى يقاتلوكم
فيه فان قاتلوكم فاقتلوهم كذلك جزاء
الكافرين
فان انتهوا فان الله غفور
رحيم وقاتلوهم حتى لا تكون فتنه ويكون
الدين
لله فان انتهوا فلا عدوان الا على
الظالمين الشهر الحرام بالشهر الحرام
والحرمات
قصاص فمن اعتدى عليكم فاعتدوا عليه بمثل
ما اعتدى عليكم واتقوا الله واعلموا ان
الله مع
المتقين وانفقوا في سبيل الله ولا تلقوا
بايديكم الى التهلكه
واحسنوا ان الله يحب
المحسنين واتموا الحج والعمره لله
فان احصرتم فما استيسر من الهدي ولا
تحلقوا رؤوسكم حتى يبلغ الهدي
محله فمن كان منكم مريضا او به اذى من
راسه ففديه من صيام او صدقه او
نسك فاذا امنتم فمن تمتع بالعمره الى الحج
فما استيسر من الهدي
فمن لم يجد فصيام ثلاثه ايام في الحج
وسبعه اذا
رجعتم تلك عشره
كامله ذلك لمن لم يكن اهله حاضر المسجد
الحرام واتقوا الله واعلموا ان الله شديد
العقاب الحج اشهر معلومات
فمن فرض فيهن الحج فلا رفث ولا فسوق ولا
جدال في
الحج وما تفعلوا من خير يعلمه
الله وتزودوا فان خير الزاد التقوى واتقون
يا اولي
الالباب ليس عليكم جناح ان تبتغوا فضلا
من
ربكم فاذا افضتم من عرفات فاذكروا الله
عند المشعر
الحرام واذكروه كما هداكم وان كنتم من
قبله لمن
الضالين ثم افيضوا من حيث افاض الناس
واستغفروا
الله ان ان الله غفور
رحيم فاذا قضيتم مناسككم فاذكروا الله
كذكركم
اباءكم او اشد
ذكرا فمن الناس من يقول ربنا اتنا في
الدنيا وما له في الاخره من
خلاق ومنهم من يقول ربنا اتنا في الدنيا
دنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار اولئك لهم نصيب مما
كسبوا والله سريع
الحساب الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه ومن ولا ومن
تبعه باحسان ال يوم الدين اما
بعد ان شاء
الله خط
[Silence]
انر الله
سبحانه وما امروا الا ليعبدوا الله مخلصين
له الدين حنفاء يقيم الصلاه وي الزكاه
وذلك الدين القيمه
‏kind requ you gu andle you in the
[Silence]
pleas so
‏as
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتران سه البينه وما امروا الا ليعبد الله
مخلصينه الدين حنفاء ويقيم الصلاه ويؤت
الزكاه وذلك وذلك دين القي
[Silence]
عهد
الصق
[Silence]
thea ‏and
allah accept for him what is for him you
know عليه
حال
came was
‏was
was محد صل عليه
وسم wants to be popular ising it for the
popular vote allah concealed is one the
things of times when i
refes me kind you know thankful to be in
the رول الله صل
علس on
the again you know is coming the same
ition yesterday i didn't mean it to be
but just happen to be in there again so
go with that take انث
عم رضي عن قال قال سمع رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم يقول ان الاعمال بالنيات وان كل
امر ما نوى فمن كان حجره الى الله ورسوله
فكان حجره ال الله ورسوله ومن كان هجره
الى الدنيا يصيبها امراه ينها فهره الى ما
حجره اليه اوقما عليه الهلام
[Silence]
‏that's
why lake
[Silence]
‏some
اللهانه الله
[Silence]
‏things make
‏ask our following questions why i
fasting and to be honest with you i i
don't think you know when i was sitting
down and working on these you know that
was a i don't think ever asked myself
either why am i fasting and some us are
years we never why
are because most of
usit ask our why are
‏right something that we are used to
repeat the next 29 days 28 days and
done dev
mind i wasing on was
a ie in a
‏youself do not your
mind and it com to mind
automatically we understand
that i purposely do not need to put my
mind into something you know you
returning back to work or i have right
wanders to mind for
[Silence]
‏was
‏there
confus
regard salam andam
conre i is i don't know i or
nobody there was ar said some there was
there was
one came up
‏uss in first
think think
‏a among
us wanders
into
force all things mind
wers make your
into ask الله سبحانه وتالى
‏in some that fores accept as was
and take
as سالول
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله
سبحان الحق لا اله الا الله محد رسول الله
ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار وكنا عذاب القبر وكنا
عذاب جنم وكنا شرته المحيا الممات وكنا
شرته الدجال ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا يا مواب الرحيم صلى الله
على محمد و اله وصحبه اجم ارحم الراحمين
اللهم امين اللهم امين اللهم امين جزاك
[Silence]
الله استقيموا واعتدلوا استووا سووا الصف
سد الخلل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذكروا الله في ايام
معدودات فمن تعجل في يومين فلا اثم عليه
ومن تاخر فلا اثم عليه لمن اتقى
واتقوا الله واعلموا انكم اليه
تحشرون ومن الناس من يعجبك قوله في الحياه
الدنيا ويشهد الله على ما في
قلبه ويشهد الله ويشهد الله على ما في
قلبه وهو الد
الخصام واذا تولى سعى في الارض ليفسد فيها
ويهلك الحرث
والنسل والله لا يحب
الفساد واذا قيل له اتق الله اخذته العزه
بالاثم فحسبه
جهنم فحسبه
جهنم ولبئس
المهاد ومن الناس من يشري نفسه
ابتغاء مرضاه الله
والله
رؤوف
بالعباد يا ايها الذين امنوا ادخلوا في
السلم
كافه ولا تتبعوا خطوات الشيطان انه لكم
عدو
مبين فان زللتم من بعد ما جاءتكم البينات
ف
فاعلموا ان الله عزيز حكيم هل ينظرون الا
ان ياتيهم الله في ظلل من الغمام
والملائكه
والملائكه وقضي الامر والى الله ترجع
الامور سلبني
اسرائيل كم
اتيناهم من ايه بينه
ومن يبدل نعمه الله من بعد ما
جاءته فاولئك
ومن يبدل نعمه الله من بعد ما جاءته فان
الله شديد
العقاب زين للذين كفروا الحياه الدنيا
ويسخرون من الذين
امنوا والذي اتقوا فوقهم يوم
القيامه والله يرزق من
يشاء بغير
حساب كان الناس امه واحده فبعث الله
النبيين مبشرين ومنذرين
وانزل وانزل معهم الكتاب بالحق ليحكم بين
الناس
ليحكم بين الناس فيما اختلفوا فيه وما
اختلف فيه الا الذين اوتوا العلم وما
اختلف فيه الا الذين اوتوه من
بعد من بعد ما
جاءتهم البينات بغيا
بينهم فهدى الله الذين امنوا لما اختلفوا
فيه من الحق
باذنه والله يهدي من
يشاء الى صراط
مستقيم ام حسبتم ان تدخلوا
الجنه ولما ياتكم مثل الذين خلوا من
قبلكم مستهم
الباساء
والضراء و
زلزلوا وزلزلوا حتى يقول الرسول والذين
امنوا معه متى نصر
الله الا ان نصر الله
قريب يسالونك ماذا
ينفقون قل ما
انفقتم من خير فللوالدين
والاقربين واليتامى والمساكين
واليتامى والمساكين وابن
السبيل وما تفعلوا من خير
فان الله به
عليم كتب عليكم القتال وهو كره لكم وعسى
ان تكرهوا شيئا وهو خير لكم
وعسى وعسى ان تحبوا شيئا وهو شر لكم والله
يعلم
وانتم لا
تعلمون يسالونك عن الشهر الحرام قتال فيه
قل قتال فيه كبير وصد عن سبيل الله وكفر
به وكفر به والمسجد حرام واخراج اهله منه
اكبر عند الله والفتنه اكبر من
القتل ولا يزالون يردونكم عن ولا يزالون
يقاتلونكم حتى يردوكم عن دينكم ان
استطاعوا ومن يرتدد منكم عن دينه فيمت وهو
كافر
فاولئك
فاولئك حبطت اعمالهم في الدنيا
والاخره واولئك اصحاب
النار هم فيها
خالدون ان الذين امنوا والذين هاجروا
وجاهدوا في سبيل الله
اولئك
اولئك يرجون رحمه
الله ان الله غفور
رحيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
يسالونك عن الخمر والميسر قل فيهما اثم
كبير ومنافع
للناس واثمهما اكبر من
نفعهما
ويسالونك ماذا ينفقون قل العفو كذلك يبين
الله لكم الايات لعلكم
تتفكرون لعلكم تتفكرون
في الدنيا
والاخره ويسالونك عن اليتامى قل اصلاح لهم
خير وان تخالطوهم فاخوانكم والله يعلم
المفسد من
المصلح ولو شاء الله لاعنتكم ان الله عزيز
حكيم ولا تنكحوا المشركات حتى يؤمن ولا
امه مؤمنه خير من
مشركه ولو
اعجبتكم ولا تنكحوا المشركين حتى يؤمنوا
ولعبد مؤمن خير من مشرك ولو
اعجبكم
اولئك يدعون الى
النار والله والله يدعو الى المغفر والله
يدعو الى الجنه والمغفره
باذنه ويبين اياته للناس لعلهم
يتذكرون ويسالونك عن المحيض قل هو اذ
فاعتزلوا
النساء في المحيض ولا
تقربوهن ولا تقربوهن
حتى
يطهرن فاذا تطهرن
فاتوهن من حيث امركم
الله ان الله يحب التوابين ويحب
المتطهرين
نساؤكم حرث لكم فاتوا حرثكم انا
شئتم وقدموا لان انفسكم واتقوا الله
واعلموا واتقوا الله واعلموا انكم ملاقوه
وبشر
المؤمنين ولا تجعلوا الله عرضه
لايمانكم ان تبروا وتتقوا وتصلحوا بين
الناس والله سميع عليم لا يؤاخذكم الله
باللغو في ايمانكم ولكن
يؤاخذكم بما كسبت
قلوبكم والله غفور حليم للذين يؤلون من
نسائهم تربص اربعه
اشهر فان
فاءوا فان الله غفور رحيم وان عزموا
الطلاق فان الله سميع عليم
والمطلقات يتربصن بانفسهن
ثلاثه
قروء ولا يحل لهن ان يكتمن ما خلق الله في
ارحامهن ان كن يؤمن
بالله ان كن يؤمن بالله يوم
الاخر وبعولتهن
احق
بردهن في ذلك ان ارادوا
اصلاحا ولهن مثل الذي عليهن
بالمعروف وللرجال
عليهن درجه والله عزيز
حكيم الطلاق مرتان فام كم بمعروف او تسريح
باحسان ولا يحل لكم ان تاخذوا مما
اتيتموهن
شيئا
الا الا ان يخافا الا يقيما حدود
الله فان خفتم الا يقيما حدود الله فلا
جناح عليهما في ما افتدت به تلك حدود الله
فلا تعتدوها
ومن يتعد حدود الله
فاولئك هم
الظالمون فان طلقها فلا تحل له من بعد حتى
تنكح زوجا غيره فان طلقها فلا جناح عليهما
يتراجعا ان ظنا ان يقيما حدود
الله وتلك حدود
الله وتلك حدود الله يبينها لقوم
يعلمون واذا طلقتم
النساء فبلغن
اجلهن فامسكوهن فامسكوهن
بمعروف او سرحوهن
بمعروف ولا تمسكوهن
ضرارا
لتعتدوا ومن يفعل ذلك فقد ظلم نفسه ولا
تتخذوا ايات الله هزوا واذكروا نعمه الله
عليكم وما انزل عليكم من الكتاب والحكمه
يعظكم
به واتقوا الله واعلموا ان الله بكل شيء
عليم واذا طلقتم
النساء فبلغن
اجلهن فلا تعضلوهن
فلا تعضلوهن
ان ينكحن
ازواجهن اذا تراضوا بينهم
بالمعروف ذلك يوعظ به من كان منكم يؤمن
بالله واليوم
الاخر ذلكم ازكى لكم
واطهر والله يعلم
وانتم لا
تعلمون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والوالدات
يرضعن
اولادهن حولين كاملين لمن اراد ان يتم
الرضاعه وعلى المولود له رزقهن
وكسوتهن
بالمعروف لا تكلف نفس الا
وسعها لا
تضار والده بولدها ولا مولود له بولده
وعلى الوارث مثل ذلك فان اراد فصالا عن
تراض منهما وتشاور
وتشاور فلا جناح
عليهما وان اردتم ان تسترضعوا
اولادكم فلا جناح عليكم اذا سلمتم ما
اتيتم
بالمعروف واتقوا الله ان الله بما تعملون
بصير والذين يتوفون منكم ويذرون ازواجا
يتربصن بانفسهن
اربعه اشهر
وعشرا فاذا بلغن
اجلهن فلا جناح عليكم فيما فعلن في
انفسهن بالمعروف
ان الله بما تعملون
خبير والله بما تعملون
خبير ولا جناح عليكم فيما عرضتم به من
خطبه
النساء او اكننتم في
انفسكم علم الله انكم ستذكرونهن
ولكن لا ت واعدو هن سرا الا الا ان تقولوا
قولا
معروفا ولا تعزموا عقده النكاح حتى يبلغ
الكتاب
اجله واعلموا ان الله يعلم ما في انفسكم
فاحذروه
واعلموا واعلموا
ان الله غفور
لا جناح عليكم ان طلقتم
النساء ما لم تمسوهن او تفرضوا لهن
فريضه ومتعوهن على الموسع قدره وعلى
المقتر قدره متاعا بالمعروف حقا على
المحسنين فان طلقتم النساء
جاء من قبل ان تمسوهن وقد فرضتم لهن فريضه
وقد فرضتم لهن فريضه فنصف ما فرضتم
الا الا ان يعفون او يعفو الذي بيده عقده
النكاح وان تعفو اقرب للتقوى
ولا تنسوا الفضل بينكم ان الله بما تعملون
بصير حافظوا على الصلوات والصلاه الوسطى
وقوموا لله وقوموا لله
قانتين فان خفتم فرجالا او
ركبانا فاذا امنتم فاذكروا الله كما علمكم
ما لم تكونوا
تعلمون والذين يتوفون منكم ويذرون ازواجا
وصيه
لازواجهم متاعا الى الحول غير
اخراج فان خرجن فلا جناح عليكم فيما فعلن
في
انفسهن من
معروف والله عزيز حكيم وللمطلقات
متاع بالمعروف حقا على
المتقين كذلك يبين الله لكم اياته لعلكم
تتفكرون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الم تر الى الذي خرجوا من ديارهم وهم
الوف حذر الموت فقال لهم الله موتوا ثم
احياهم
ان الله لذو فضل على الناس ولكن اكثر
الناس لا
يشكرون وقاتلوا في سبيل الله واعلموا ان
الله سميع
عليم من ذا الذي يقرض الله قرضا حسنا
فيضاعفه له اضعافا
كثيره والله يقبض ويبسط واليه
يرجعون الم تر الى الملا من بني
اسرائيل من بعد موسى اذ قالوا لنبي
لهم اذ قالوا لنبي لهم ابعث لنا ملكا
نقاتل في سبيل الله قال هل عسيتم ان كتب
عليكم القتال الا
تقاتلوا قالوا وما لنا الا نقاتل في سبيل
الله وقد اخرجنا من ديارنا
وابنائنا فلما كتب عليهم القتال تولوا الا
قليلا
منهم والله عليم
بالظالمين وقال لهم نبيهم ان الله قد بعث
لكم طالوت
ملكا قالوا انا يكون له الملك علينا ونحن
احق بالملك منه ولم يؤت سعه من المال قال
ان الله اصطفاه عليكم وزاده بسطه في العلم
والجسم والله يؤتي ملكه من يشاء
والله واسع
عليم وقال لهم نبيهم ان ايه ملكه ان
ياتيكم ان ياتيكم التابوت فيه سكينه من
ربكم
وبقيه
وبقيه مما ترك ال موسى وال هارون تحمل
الملائكه ان في ذلك لايه لكم ان كنتم
مؤمنين فلما فصل طالوت بالجنود قال ان
الله مبتليكم بنهر فمن شرب منه فليس مني
ومن لم يطعمه فانه مني الا
الا من اغترف
غرفه بيده فشربوا منه الا قليلا
منهم فلما جاوزه هو والذين امنوا معه
قالوا قالوا لا طاقه لنا اليوم بجالوت
وجنوده قال الذين يظنون انهم ملا ق الله
كم من فئه قليله غلبت فئه كثيره باذن
الله والله مع
الصابرين فلم
فهزموهم باذن
الله فلما برزوا لجالوت
وجنوده قالوا ربنا افرغ علينا صبرا
قالوا ربنا افرغ علينا صبرا وثبت اقدامنا
وانصرنا على القوم
الكافرين
فهزموهم باذن الله وقتل داوود جالوت واتاه
الله واتاه الله الملك
والحكمه واتاه الله الملك والحكمه وعلم
مما
يشاء ولولا دفع الله الناس بعضهم ببعض
لفسدت الارض ولكن الله ذو فضل على
العالمين تلك ايات الله نتلوها عليك
بالحق
وانك لمن المرس
مسلين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الشفعه والوتر ان شاء
الله
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما
شاء الله انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى ثم لا يموت
فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا وال الاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مال يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اذا
جاء نصر الله
والفتح رايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك واستغفره
انه كان
توابا الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليه ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه ملا السماء والارض وملا ما
بينهما ومل ما شئت من شيء
بعد اللهم تم نورك فهديت فلك الحمد عظم
حلمك فعفوت فلك الحمد بسطت يدك فاعطيت فلك
الحمد فلك الحمد يا ربنا على كل
حال اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت وتوفنا فيمن توليت وتولنا فيمن
توليت وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت واصرف عنا
برحمتك شر ما قدرت وقضيت
انك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى
عليك انه لا يذل من واليت ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت نستغفرك ربنا من جميع الذنوب
والخطايا ونتوب اليك اللهم اقسم لنا من
خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا وبين معصيتك
ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك ومن اليقين
ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا ومتعنا
اللهم
باسماعنا
وابصارنا وقواتنا ابدا ما
ابقيت واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا على
من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عادانا ولا تسلط علينا بذنوبنا من لا
يخافك فينا ولا
يرحمنا اللهم لا تجعل الدنيا اكبر همنا
ولا مبلغ علمنا ولا الى النار
مصيرنا اللهم انا عبيدك بني عبيدك بن بنو
امائك نواصينا بيدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل
فينا قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به
نفسك انزلته في كتابك او علمته احدا من
خلقك او استاثرت به في علم الغيب
عندك ان تجعل القران العظيم ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا وجلاء
احزاننا وذهاب همومنا وغمومنا
وسابقنا الى جناتك جنات النعيم اللهم تقبل
منا انك انت السميع العليم وتب علينا يا
ربنا انك انت التواب
الرحيم اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
والتابعين واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏l